snapchat is all about posting pictures
and videos that are deleted after a
certain amount of time but some snapchat
stories are so hilarious we really wish
they didn't have to disappear pic you're
new to our channel don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up because today we're
sharing 10 snapchats that shouldn't be a
race after 10 seconds within the fold
this girl's entire life was summed up in
one yearbook photo if you look closely
the bold of the page completely covers
her entire face it's almost like she's
not even there line him up look at this
adorable dog who's waiting patiently
behind a line of stuffed animals
his owner captioned the picture he
thinks he has to wait in line to get a
treat
let's just hope his weight wasn't too
long too much time what happens when
your bottle of time seasoning completely
blows up all over your hands too much
time on your hands of course pretty
genius right who wore it better we
cannot stop laughing at the snapchatter
comparing his teacher's outfit to his
pink highlighter we're sure all his
snapchat followers had a good laugh when
this was posted and hopefully teacher
has a good sense of humor too making
friends we kind of feel bad for the
snapchat user but at the same time we
can't help holdbacks laughter during a
lonely day of Solitude he drew some
friends using the apps drawing tool but
just moments later his cartoon friends
walked off and left him all alone again
naked men at first glance this super
hilarious snapchat looks like a naked
hairy man lying in bed what is actually
a dog's butt the resemblance is striking
don't you agree
a real-life Harry Potter someone was
convinced they had just spotted a
real-life Harry Potter a snapchat user
posted this photo of a man who looks a
lot like the actor who played Harry
Daniel Radcliffe the caption of this
photo is what really makes it golden a
Hogwarts degree isn't worth much these
days how do people come up with this
stuff
laundry day becoming an adult means you
have to clean up after yourself cook
your own food and do your own laundry
but a snapchat user got their butt
kicked by life when their laundry went
up in flames let's hope this little
incident didn't to tear them from doing
their laundry again in the near future
come play with us to pay homage to the
movie The Shining this man used emojis
to recreate the two creepy little girls
who said come play with us Danny in the
classic movie
rough neighborhood if you thought your
neighborhood was bad just get a load of
it one snapchat user close to the photo
of a child's tricycle locked up to a
pole good luck trying to steal this
kid's bike twinsies
this student suffered an embarrassing
scenario that turned into a snapchat
classic moment during a trip to the
restroom she noticed her outfit was an
exact replica of the bathroom walls
pretty gross but absolutely hilarious at
the same time balloon head this student
turned a dull moment in class into a
snapchat story we wish we could have
never deleted he stuffed a balloon
inside a hoodie and propped it up on a
desk to resemble a student his setup was
so convincing the teacher even handed
out class work to the balloon head
sweeping Sean when Sean fell asleep
his body transformed him into a Disney
Princess using snapchats drawing tools
Sean morphed into Sleeping Beauty and in
another photo
Aladdin shows up to serenade Sean with
the timeless song a whole new world now
to self never fall asleep in front of
Sean's friends sue you while in class a
snapchat user was seated behind a
student named sue you the caption reads
this girl better go to law school
because of her unique name can you
imagine how hilarious it would be to be
represented by a lawyer named sue you
under the sea there are definitely some
pretty talented people on snapchat like
this guy who created some funky artwork
using a bunch of vibrant colors he
transformed himself into Ariel from The
Little Mermaid all that's missing is his
force and his print which of these
hilarious snapchats is your favorite
react in the comments section below and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up
[Music]
you